y lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
empezar con el porcentaje en masa y ver
si con el porcentaje en masa podemos
encontrar la fórmula empírica de una
molécula digamos que tenemos una bolsa y
que de alguna forma sabemos que esa
bolsa contiene 73% 73% de mercurio y el
resto es decir el 27 por ciento es de
cloro basándonos en esto podemos obtener
la fórmula molecular de la molécula que
tenemos en esa bolsa yo los invito a que
pause en el vídeo y traten de resolver
los solos primero bueno vamos a suponer
que tenemos 100 gramos en total podrían
ser mil 57 o el número que quieran pero
supongamos que tenemos 100 gramos para
que sea más fácil vamos a suponer que
tenemos 100 gramos de esa molécula que
contiene 73% de mercurio y 27 por ciento
de cloro entonces con esto
su posición eso significa que el 73% de
mercurio corresponde a 73 gramos y el 27
por ciento de cloro corresponde a 27
gramos y para que quede más claro esto
es mercurio y esto es cloro ok ahora
necesitamos saber cuántos moles de
mercurio son 73 gramos y cuántos moles
de cloro son 27 gramos para eso vamos a
usar esta tabla periódica aquí tenemos
el peso molecular bueno en realidad es
la masa promedio de todos los isótopos
que se han encontrado en la naturaleza y
miren el peso molecular del mercurio es
de 200 puntos 59 eso significa voy a
escribirlo por acá que un mol un molde
mercurio es igual a 200 puntos 59 gramos
200 puntos 59 gramos
y lo mismo podemos hacer con el peso
molecular del cloro que es de 35.400 53
entonces un molde cloro recuerden este
es un valor promedio obtenido de todos
los isótopos encontrados en la
naturaleza entonces un molde cloro es
igual a 35.400 53 gramos
ahora ya que tenemos esto
aproximadamente cuántos moles de
mercurio será esto aproximadamente
cuántos moles de cloro es esto bueno
digo aproximadamente porque para obtener
la fórmula empírica a partir de los
porcentajes en masa a veces tenemos que
redondear y los números no serán exactos
por eso digo aproximadamente entonces
cuántos moles tenemos aquí bueno esto es
igual a 73 entre 200 puntos 59 porque si
un molde es igual a 200 puntos 59 gramos
y nosotros sólo tenemos 73 ésta es la
fracción de un mol entonces tenemos esta
fracción de moles de mercurio recuerden
los moles son un número relacionado con
el número de avogadro pero solo
calculemos esto tenemos 73 entre 200
puntos 59
esto es igual a 0.36 dejémoslo en 0.3
164 aproximadamente tenemos 0.3 164
moles de mercurio ahora vamos con el
cloro esto es igual a 27 entre 30 y
5.453 moles de cloro y esto es igual a
aproximadamente usemos la calculadora 27
entre 30 y 5.453 es igual a 0.76 2
entonces tenemos cero puntos 760 y dos
moles de cloro así que cuál será la
relación entre el mercurio y el cloro o
mejor dicho entre cloro y mercurio
porque tenemos más cloro bueno recuerden
que esto es solo un número cero puntos
760 y dos moles
son 0 punto 762 por el número de
avogadro átomos de cloro y estos son 0
punto 364 por el número de avogadro
átomos de mercurio entonces literalmente
podemos ver esto como una relación este
es un cierto número de moles y este es
otro cierto número de moles pero cuál es
la relación entre el cloro y el mercurio
bueno a simple vista parece una relación
2 a 1 vamos a verificarlo si dividimos
esto entre 0.3 639 para que sea una
aproximación miren esto es prácticamente
2 cuando nos encontramos con algo que es
tan fácil de explicar como esto tal vez
piensen que hay algún error pero en
realidad podemos decir que es una
aproximación a eso me refiero cuando
digo que hallar la fórmula empírica a
partir del porcentaje en masa es una
aproximación así
en este caso podemos decir que la
relación cloro mercurio es de
aproximadamente 2 a 1 es decir tenemos 2
cloro por cada mercurio entonces podemos
decir que por cada mercurio tenemos dos
claros dos claros entonces basados en
estos porcentajes descubrimos que la
molécula que tenemos en la bolsa es
cloruro de mercurio todos se les llama
así porque el cloro es muy electro
negativo es un agente oxidante toma
electrones de otros elementos o al menos
los acapara y en este caso como tenemos
dos claros y cada cloro acapara un
electrón entonces los claros acaparan
dos electrones del mercurio y cuando
perdemos electrones o más bien cuando
acaparan esos electrones
el mercurio es oxidado y en este caso el
estado de oxidación del mercurio es
dos de sus electrones son acaparados uno
por cada cloro entonces este es el
cloruro de mercurio donde el mercurio
tiene un estado de oxidación igual a
todos y esto significa que
aproximadamente tenemos dos cloro por
cada mercurio